science that says there are two minds
that are operating at the same time one
is called the conscious mind and one is
called the subconscious mind I say
What's the difference the conscious mind
is where you are as a spirit an entity a
unique identity you are in that
conscious mind and perceiving the world
I say what about the subconscious mind
it's not a creative mind the
subconscious mind is habits things that
you've learned and you've experienced in
your life and they become habits so the
subconscious mind is not thinking
creating a subconscious mind push the
button play the behavior when we are in
our conscious mind we are connecting our
spirituality to the biology and the
physical planet that we're in and that
is a creative mind that's the one you
wake up in the morning and say oh I wish
I had this and I desire that and these
are the things I want and then you go
out and start the day and then guess
what
95 of the day you are not operating from
the conscious mind science is recognize
95 of the day because we are thinking 95
percent of the day our behavior is now
controlled by the subconscious mind I go
okay so what's the difference in the
final conclusion of this is the
conscious mind with your creativity has
your wishes and your desires
the subconscious mind was programmed by
other people your mother your father
your siblings and your community so what
is the difference you wake up with a
wish and a desire of what you want
and then the rest of the day you play
the programs that you got from other
people that don't answer your wishes and
don't support your desires and all you
see is the consequence of it and go oh
my God why is it not working the answer
is because you don't see because
remember the name is subconscious below
conscious so when that behavior is
playing psychologists will tell us 70
percent or more of the programs in the
subconscious are disempowering
self-sabotaging and limiting behaviors
so the simple reality is this we have
great wishes and desires and yet our
life is not controlled by that our life
is controlled by the programming and
that programming is the disempowering
program so all you see is the
consequence of the invisible
subconscious which will sabotage all the
desires and wishes you have and then to
conclude that
what if you just didn't default to the
subconscious what if you just stayed in
the conscious mind that's called being
Mindful and why is it relevant because
when you stay conscious keep your mind
present you are the creator of your life
and when people are in mindfulness they
manifest their wishes their desires and
their happiness so for all of us it's
sort of a wake-up call you think you're
running your life with your wishes and
desires it's an illusion you're really
running your life with your programs
acquired from other people eighty
percent of our inner dialogue is
negative and 95 of those thoughts are
the same thoughts that we had yesterday
that's what Beth Handel taught me she's
garyvee's life coach we had an awesome
session together and it really hit home
imagine that 80 percent of the thoughts
that you've got 80 percent
are negative we are beating ourselves up
we are telling ourselves that we can't
do things it's not even our friends and
family the people around us telling us
that we suck it's us it's ourselves we
tell ourselves we're not good enough we
can't do this we're not strong enough
smart enough we're from the wrong
country we look the wrong way you know
we're too young we're too old whatever
it is 80 of our thoughts are negative
and then 95 of those negative thoughts
are the exact same negative thoughts
that we had yesterday it's no wonder why
we stay small it's no wonder why we stay
stuck because we've created this
reinforcing Loop of negativity this is
why I think the world's biggest problem
is lack of belief I'm on a mission every
day wake up try to make content try to
spread the message to help people
believe in themselves more I think lack
of belief is the single biggest problem
in the world and I also believe that
everybody has Michael Jordan level
genius at something like you are the
greatest you're the greatest in the
world at something and it's not what you
went to school for and it's not what
your parents did for living probably is
something completely different and you
have to have the courage to go off and
Chase it and find it and and do it
because the woman who solves cancer
should have already solved it by now but
she never believed in herself enough to
go to medical school and now she's a
manager an accounting firm which doesn't
like her life right I mean this is this
is where most of us are stuck most
people wake up and they drive the job
that that we don't like most people are
stuck and barely hanging on and do not
like their life and feel like they're
not contributing they're not they're not
making any kind of difference they're
not doing anything meaningful or
impactful at all in the world that's
most people imagine waking up and that's
your daily reality that may be you
or that may have been who you were and
you still describe it and try to improve
and get better but if 80 of those
thoughts that come through your head
conscious or unconscious are negative I
think a lot of conscious thoughts are
negative too
not just the subconscious the conscious
thoughts are negative you telling
yourself that you can't do something and
you're not good enough and then 95 are
the same as yesterday that we've just
created this this Loop this this
negative thinking Loop so how do we
break it how do we break free how do we
solve that problem well that's that's
the billion dollar question and that's
what I wake up
every day trying to fix and I can give
you a couple things that I've worked on
that I found helpful and hopefully helps
move the needle they don't have all the
answers but but some of these might help
the first one is to change your
environment the environment makes such a
huge difference for who you are and your
daily habits and what you believe about
yourself and the environment is not just
the people who are around you although
that definitely helps you know if you've
got negative friends or family around
you you want to eliminate them
completely or spend a lot less time with
them because it's really really really
hard to have a beautiful plant grow when
it's just you know toxic waste being
poured on top of them doable but really
really difficult and so changing that
can really help and
one of the best ways I found to do it is
content
it's content it's why I make so much
content for these channels that
hopefully you wake up today and there's
a piece of content there waiting for you
whether it's me or showcasing somebody
else across all my channels or making
multiple pieces of content every single
day to try to hit it in the right way
maybe today's message with the right
voice is the one that makes a difference
for you and if you can shift
the amount of entertainment you're doing
or just shutting off the world some of
the content that you consume just helps
you shut off the world and Escape versus
educational content that helps you learn
improve get better and solve the problem
right entertainment is let's forget
about the problem just laugh at
something else
education is let's learn to actually fix
the problem that is happening in our
life right I want to lean in on that a
lot more it doesn't mean that
entertainment doesn't exist in your life
it's not only education but if you can
shift the needle towards education to be
around the people who inspire you even
if you've never met them
it can really move the needle for your
your inner dialogue and your
self-confidence so the thing that saved
me in my first business in doing this
was modeling Bill Gates or Microsoft
when I I quit on my business partner I
struggled I didn't know you know I felt
worthless nothing was working I was
working every day and just no results in
in looking at Bill Gates's story that
that changed my life it saved my
business it allowed me to keep going
because now I had a little bit of hope
that Bill Gates could do it maybe I
could too and the more you surround
yourself with those people
the more you'll feel like you can do it
too so do an audit how many people in
your life the the actual humans that you
know and also just the people that you
subscribe to that you follow how many of
them make you feel better about yourself
and for too many people it's it's not
enough you know it's
look at who you follow on YouTube look
at who subscribe to look at who you're
connecting with on Instagram you know if
you're loading your phone you're going
through Instagram or you're watching
YouTube videos how many times have you
gone through it and all of a sudden an
hour has gone by and you were mindlessly
watching videos or even worse made you
feel worse about yourself you ever felt
that you watch a video and then you feel
worse about yourself afterwards or
you're following somebody and it makes
you feel worse about yourself you have a
choice to unfollow those people this is
not Instagram's fault or YouTube's fault
you can take accountability here you
have a choice to unfollow those people
and then a choice to follow the people
who make you feel better about yourself
that's my aim with all these videos I
want to leave you with strategies but
also more belief in yourself at the end
of every video and if I do that awesome
you want more belief in your life come
back you know another shot of espresso
tomorrow morning we're here and if I
don't do that cool thank you for giving
it a shot and and don't quit on that go
find somebody else who gives you the
motivation inspiration that you need
and so you can make a conscious choice
because it's so easy to stay stuck it's
so easy to stay small it's so easy to to
be the one that pours in other people
and not have anybody pour into us and
you need to make a conscious choice to
to raise your environment to change your
environment and it doesn't mean you have
to go move to a different country or
move to a fancier house or anything else
you start by just changing who you
associate with even at a mass scale
right
I've learned a lot from Steve Jobs I've
been inspired by Oprah Winfrey my
favorite entrepreneur of all time is AP
giannini who started Bank of America
these are people who I've never met
you know and and in the case of jobs in
Janine I never you know will meet
because they've passed but I've been
inspired by them and they've made me
better and they've taught me and I've
learned from them and they've inspired
me and I get courage from them
because I've consumed their content and
you can do that too
it's just being intentional about it so
that when you raise your environment you
raise your life
the second thing is try not to do it
alone
it's really hard to go after
a goal to change your mindset to
accomplish big things when you're doing
it all by yourself you know it this is
why a lot of people quit
because you might have one one amazing
day or you watch The Right video you
have the right experience and it's like
that I want this is this is the life I
want you ever had that right like this
is the life that I want this is who I
want to be this is this is where I could
go you have a glimpse of a potential
future that you could be it's like I
want that and and you actually feel in
your heart that you can be that you can
accomplish that right has that happened
to you and then what happens the next
day you wake up and it's kind of gone
and then the next day it's completely
gone and then you're back to your old
life and the limiting beliefs and the
habits and and you know you gain back
the 20 pounds and like how did I end up
back here I thought I fixed this right
has that ever happen to you
a lot of it is because you're doing it
alone
and this took me a long time to figure
out
as an introverted person as a shy person
as somebody who doesn't like asking for
help
um
as someone who's afraid of disappointing
people
being a part of a community
is not
it just sounds super scary to me
we just did our seven day challenge for
built to serve and a bunch of people
join movement makers I had almost 100
people join movement makers at the end
of it and it's people who want to be
thought leaders and want to be speakers
and authors and coaches and course
creators and membership creators and all
of this stuff there's a big impact that
spread your message and I was giving
people
a lot of uh
[Music]
not just encouragement but respect like
the people who ended up joining I just
had incredible respect for
because I wouldn't have done it if I go
back to 19 year old Evan when I started
my first business I wouldn't have done
it I wouldn't have had the courage to do
it I wouldn't have joined the group
we had people sharing their videos like
tell us about your your who your why
your how is your this methodology from
the book but make a video you know
sharing your purpose and your biggest
pain of all time and some of these you
know kind of deep things that you have
to record and share and I mean it was
optional not everybody did it but in
doing that
for a lot of people it was their first
video that they've ever done
for a lot of people it was the first
time they've even shared their story to
anybody that they were sharing things in
the group that they hadn't told their
spouse
you know or their family or their best
friend and now they're making a video in
their car
ing their story
[Music]
and you see them become liberated you
see them you see them start super scared
and Afraid and unsure and fixing their
hair and you know apologizing for the
lighting not being good and them being
in the car and not knowing what they're
doing to then just seeing the
transformation of somebody
going through the Cocoon you know being
a caterpillar and turn into a butterfly
and sharing their story for the first
time and I was in awe because I I
couldn't imagine me doing that at 19
when I started my first business
[Music]
I was too afraid to join a community I
was too afraid of being judged
I was too afraid of being not good
enough
and that kept me small
I kept my growth really slow
[Music]
fortunately I kept going you know if
you've seen my my
my chart on my website where I show how
much I've grown every year over year
over year over year where I've been took
five years to get the seven thousand
subscribers or something like that
and I just kept going and the one thing
that I've got was just tenacity and
drive and I will just keep going in the
face of adversity
but I made it just incredibly hard on
myself being alone not being open to
sharing with my friends what I was
struggling with being never joining the
community
so I think that can really help you you
know I think I think trying to go and
change your mindset and accomplish big
things that nobody around you has done
yet and there are some days that you
feel incredibly inspired and motivated
and Powerful like yeah I can do this but
you're probably not living there most of
the time
foreign
what if you did or what if you lived
kind of close to that most of the time
and point number one of raising your
environment can definitely help
but Point number two is just don't try
to do it alone
even if it's one person you don't have
to join mover makers you have to join a
group
but even just one person
one person who you can talk to you can
connect with
who you can you know share your stories
with not just complain to not not talk
about how hard everything is and just
have somebody to vent to but somebody
who supports you
if you had a group of people who
supported you
well you felt welcome we felt like you
weren't alone in this journey we felt
like people understood you
and we're actually genuinely cheering
you on to go you know become the person
that you want to be
Everything Changes
so raise your environment
get a community and watch your impact
happen
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
I was looking for relationships I kept
failing at them okay I end up in the
Caribbean teaching at a medical school
the universe throws this into my lap the
perfect pickup line in the whole world
is sort of like hey if you're not doing
anything you want to come and stay in my
villa in the Caribbean and hang out I
have a villa on the beach and I got my
own place and uh blah blah blah and I
still wasn't able to find anybody but I
kept looking because I said I need a
relationship I need
good job so so I meet this woman who
comes off of some yacht and she's you
know I've got a future that's like
she'll do what she wants and I thought
well if you're not doing anything why
don't you uh you want to come and stay
with me and my Villa on this beautiful
island she looked at me and she looked
at me and then she said I can't be with
you and I sort of like stop for a moment
and she looked at me and she says you're
too needy
it hit me I said oh my God what am I
looking for a relationship why because
you're not happy so if you're looking
for a relationship because you're not
happy then you're depending on that
relationship to make you happy so that's
not a a nice relationship it's
codependency if I give you this place to
stay you will make me happy that's a
trade you know it's like yes and after
she said that I was stunned for a moment
I can't be with you you're too needy she
said and I was stuck and then all of a
sudden I said Thank you thank you very
much it was sort of a slap in the face
right the blessing in disguise right it
totally was it was like wake up and I
walked away from that and I looked at my
life and said you got this most amazing
job you teach a couple days a week you
live in the Caribbean you've got a villa
you got money in your pocket because you
get paid and there's nothing to buy in
the Caribbean anyways I got I say you're
healthy you got money you got a great
place to live you have the most
wonderful job I go you can't be happy
with with that that's what I said to
myself
I said how can I you know I'm looking
for this person to make me happy I said
oh no first I make me happy yeah and
then when I make me happy
that changed and it did what happened is
I stopped bitching and started to enjoy
look don't you love where you live yeah
I love where I live do you love Lucia oh
I love the sea you like it oh I love my
job and all of a sudden I started
focusing on hey these are things I love
and guess what
I didn't need anybody
that's when he created abundance and
that's when people became attracted to
you right 100 because once I didn't need
them I wasn't like yeah come here I was
like ass I don't care it's fascinating
how it works and they showed up they
showed up because I did not need that
was the word because need puts pressure
on that other person that they have to
provide and then they didn't have to
provide it was like hey let me hang out
with you I don't have to provide
anything I could just be me I go yeah
you'll be you I'd be me we have a great
time
and that was the beginning of
reprogramming a need for a relationship
until I was happy with myself and until
that happened once I was happy with
myself and I didn't need a relationship
you should have seen how many
opportunities showed up that were never
there in my life before because the need
part pushed them away money is the
equivalent of energy so you can buy
energy with your cash and the
significant against about that is just
if you're Frugal and take care of your
money and keep a balance then you always
have this energy in your bank account
energy in which you can live however
obviously if you waste this energy then
you actually interfere with your own
Survival so you don't really want to go
out and just throw away your money and
so basically I really want to show you
that this is an important insight into
the nature of our own health and our
biology and the world recreate in this
regard that our biological system the
cells rely on energy without energy
there's no life so fundamentally you
have an energy budget that gives you
life and in fact in the body energy is
in coins called ATP molecules that
represent units of energy so in fact
biologists refer to ATP as the coin of
the realm the significance of ATP is
this is that ATP molecules are like
units of gasoline like gallon of gas
that are used to fuel our biological
processes so to stay alive we have to
have all this ATP so there's an ATP
account in your body right now but the
question is how do you use this ATP and
now here's an important fact that 25 of
the total energy in your whole body is
used to operate your brain so all of a
sudden you start to recognize that the
brain uses energy at the rate of muscles
of a marathon runner so a brain and
muscle activity are pretty much the same
and so why is this important because as
you're using your brain as you're using
your thinking you are actually using
energy now why is this relevant the
answer is very simply this because the
way we've been using our thoughts are
not necessarily productive a matter of
fact sometimes our investments of our
thoughts are actually counterproductive
because our thoughts create a reality
that we then have to overcome so
basically it says that we must start to
become aware of our thoughts and why is
this important because thoughts
represent units of energy every time you
have a thought you use energy why this
becomes relevant is if I give you a
checkbook for your bank account you
don't go down the street and just write
checks to people like oh hey you're a
nice looking guy here's 10 bucks for you
and oh here little girl go out and buy
yourself a little car here's a thousand
dollars for you and you don't give away
your money why because giving away your
money is giving away your life so
basically you become very frugal when
you have a checkbook in your hand now
what I'm trying to tell you is this you
have an energy budget in your body the
energy is what keeps you alive when you
start using energy and writing checks
where you get no return from your energy
then it's exactly the same as writing
checks out of your bank checkbook and
giving away your cash so why this
becomes important is the biology of
belief reveals how our thoughts create
our reality and if you start investing
in thoughts that are counterproductive
thoughts like fear or what am I going to
do and how am I going to escape this
problem or how's this going to go wrong
and all these other kinds of thoughts
that are negative kinds of thoughts then
realize this you are actually not just
using your energy for having these slots
but these thoughts are also what come
into your reality what you focus on with
your thoughts your brain will manifest
as reality I was cloning stem cells back
in 1967. 40 years ago and the
significance was while I was doing this
research I was also teaching medical
students so I was teaching medical
students the foundation of how cells
work the conventional story out of the
textbook genes control life what we call
the genetic determinism the belief that
genes control your traits Behavior your
physical characteristics Etc and what my
research revealed when I was studying
the stem cells was this very profound I
put one stem cell in a Petri dish all by
itself and it would divide every 10 to
12 hours so it'd be 2 4 8 16 cells 32
cells after about two so I have
thousands of cells in the petri dish but
what was unique they were all
genetically identical but then I did the
experiment experiment was to take some
cells out of the dish and put them into
a separate dish with a different
environment okay and so the environment
is a culture medium but the culture
medium to cells is like the world that
we live in it's got the air the water
the food all the things in it so I take
the cells out of my stem cell dish put
them in a separate dish with a different
environment and the cells form muscle
but then I went back to the same dish
with genetically identical cells in it
took some cells out put them in a
different environment and they form bone
and then I went back to the same dish
with genetically identical cells and put
them in a third petri dish with a
different environment and they form fat
cells and there I was confronted with
this reality all the cells are
genetically identical but they had
different fade fat muscle bone I say
simple question what controls the fate
of cells and the answer is the
environment it was the only thing that
was different because they were all
genetically identical so I started to
really say oh my goodness here I am
teaching genes control life to the
medical students and yet the cells were
revealing to me that hey they all had
the same genes but it was the
environment that I put them in and so
the environment controlled their life
and a very simple experiment that is
very profound for us today is if I took
my dish with plastic petri dish with
cells in it and moved it from a healthy
environment to a less and healthy
environment the cells get sick and if I
were a doctor of cells I you might say
well what kind of drugs would you give
these cells and it turns out no you
don't give the cells any drugs you just
take the dish from the bad environment
put it back into a good environment and
the cells will innately naturally come
back to health again well how do you
change the subconscious mind say how did
it learn in the first place
I say what was the first one I say Theta
seven years brain was functioning lower
vibration than Consciousness you have to
slow down the brain to a much slower
vibration then it goes into the
subconscious mind that's why um
hypnotherapists in the old days they had
a watch and they would swing it back and
forth so the watch would swing and they
would tell the person you're getting
sleepy you're getting tired and the
reason they say that is because that
shuts down the conscious vibration and
the next vibration is Theta which is
hypnosis so to get you into hypnosis
first I have to get your conscious brain
to stop
and then in hypnosis State Theta the
vibration Theta then whatever is coming
from the outside is not going into my
conscious mind whatever I see on the
outside is going into my subconscious
program
so if you want to change the
subconscious you have to talk to the
subconscious and go how you do that well
number one hypnosis and I go oh well I
need to see the hypnotherapist I go no
this is the cool part I say why I said
we have different vibrations the lowest
vibration is Delta is sleep the next
higher vibration is Theta hypnosis
imagination the next higher vibration is
Alpha calm Consciousness and the next
higher vibration is called beta which is
like School room like what we're doing
here Consciousness okay I go so why is
it rub I said when you're asleep you're
at the lowest and when you start to wake
up you go up first of theta and that's
like in the morning where you're half
awake and half asleep and and then I
said but then when you're awake you're
an alpha now you're in Consciousness and
then when you go to work you're in beta
which is like the work in Consciousness
but when you come home it reverses so I
come home from work I'm in beta but I
relax oh the Consciousness vibration
slows down the alpha and here's the fact
the moment that the vibrations get a
little lower than Alpha Consciousness is
now shut off for the night you're
sleeping yeah but there's a period of
time after Alpha shuts off before it
reaches Delta the lowest one there's a
period of time of theta I go Y is it
relevant I said you put earphones on
and the moment and you play a program of
what of what you want a self-help
program of how to make a relationship be
healthy and do a job whatever you get
the program self-help program I say you
put it on on a CD player let's say and
you put the earphones on and while
you're still awake just before you go to
sleep you can hear what's going on but
the moment you fall asleep conscious
Minds shut off but guess what Theta is
on the work is getting done right right
you're getting a self-hypnosis with the
earphone so whatever the you didn't hear
it you were sleeping the subconscious
mind was hearing it and when you repeat
that that's how you put a new program in
so that's number one self-hypnosis how
many people may think well hold on a
second so I can take five minutes and I
can totally change my life and that's
all I need and I think that's a really a
wonderful possibility
but the probability is this are you
going to hit the right statement that is
the one that you need to change your
life okay uh let's say someone's
overweight and they say in their mind I
I am you know a weight a number they
like I am 125 pounds and you're not uh
and I say uh so I want to change my
weight and I put a program in I'm going
to lose weight and I go but wait that
extra poundage uh that might be due to
protection okay what do you mean I say
if eyes as an as a young person was
abused then the Consciousness is if I'm
a heavy person they won't bother me
anymore and so the weight isn't due to
just eating food
is due to I am safer being heavy than I
am I say well if you want to change your
weight you can talk about the weight all
you want but until you adjust the
problem from the the fear uh you know
that I'm going to be abused that's where
the problem came from it didn't come
from eating food over here so I said
yeah well you can change beliefs uh
sometimes I like to give a visual a
matter of fact I visualize a big spider
web which has like circles and then
lines coming out you know like a web
okay and so there are links as you go
around there's also anchors where the
web is anchored at a couple places and I
go each belief is like a link
and that spider weapon you can do one
link on another link on another link
that really change the spider web but if
you do a belief that is an anchor and
you change the anchor belief and that
anchor lets go
the web will collapse that's possible
the point is this sometimes a police
statement knocks out a link
but when you really hit it just right
you knock out a support and when you
knock out a major support the whole web
collapses instead of just a link at a
time which could take it down but it's
much harder they all have approximately
50 trillion cells in our body and these
cells are all self-sufficient they have
their own memory they have their own
immune system and in fact you're also
going to say that for 2.75 billion years
there was only one celled organisms
alive on the planet yeah and the nature
is as a single cell evolved to be the
most intelligent and could be it ran
into a physical limitation because
intelligence is physically tied up with
the membrane or skin of the cell you can
only have so much membrane so Evolution
apparently stopped it was like two and a
half billion years just a single cell
organism then I said well how can you
have more Evolution the answer is cells
decided to come together in community
because when cells come into Community
they share awareness so there's more
awareness with 10 cells and there is
with one cell and there's more awareness
with a million or a billion or a
trillion so when you look at a human
being while we see ourselves as single
entities the truth is we are made out of
50 trillion amoeba like cells and so our
bodies this giant community
and why what makes it very exciting as
you mentioned is well in my own work
with cloning cells I can take a cell out
of your body and it could live outside
of you why it has its own intelligence
it has essentially every function in
your body is present in a Cell so my
seven-year-old Vision manifests to be
true when I got older to realize cells
are Miniature people and then you say
well what about happens in the human
body and I go this is where the issue
comes in is because you have 50 trillion
cells living in community but your mind
is the government
when a government works in harmony with
the people then the people thrive and
the community is is in good health and
grows but when a government is not
really supportive or not working in in
harmony with a community then the
government can cause the the the nature
of that Community to fall apart and even
lead to to the end of the community well
that's what we're finding out our mind
is the government and when we entertain
Harmony and and the right living and
balance with nature and with each other
then we provide our 50 trillion cells
with very life-supporting information
and chemistry so Harmony means
giving the body good food yes not being
stressed out absolutely living in a in a
happy environment yes basically it says
uh it's as I said when I had my petri
dish of cells if I put it from a healthy
environment to a bad environment the
cells got sick but you didn't have to
give them drugs uh but all you did is
take the the dish from the bad
environment and put it in a good
environment and the joke which I like to
tell people is well this happens in the
plastic petri dishes but guess what we
are skin covered petri dishes underneath
our skin is 50 trillion cells living in
addition the culture medium is the blood
and so when I change the culture meaning
in a plastic dish I changed the fate of
the cells and I say well then what
controls the culture medium my blood the
chemistry and the answer is my thoughts
influence my brain and the Brain
releases chemistry that matches my
thoughts so when I'm in stress or I'm
afraid of the world I release different
chemistry into the blood than if I open
up my eyes and I find myself in love I
release my completely different
chemistry and it's like well all I have
to ask in individual is how do you feel
when you're in total love or how do you
feel when you're in fear and the answer
is well I feel totally different guess
what all the cells are bathed in that
chemistry and so the the feeling of Love
produces totally different chemistry in
the blood chemistry that supports growth
and healing of the body and supports the
immune system and in contrast when we
perceive reasons to be afraid and we
release stress hormones into our body we
actually shut off the growth mechanisms
and the immune system to serve to save
the energy why because if you believe
you're going to have to run from that
lion you want all the energy available
to run from a line so when a person is
in stress they allocate their energy
reserves for fight or flight but take it
at the expense of the health of the
system the immune part of the system and
so the more stress you're under the more
bad chemistry in a sense of not
supporting you you that you experience
uh and and it was a very important point
in our Evolution stress or fear was not
the main stay of Life the Mainstay of
life was to be happy and live in the
harmony of the environment every now and
then a saber-toothed tiger would come
okay now it's time to be stressed out
now it's time to run but the point is
once you escape from the saber-toothed
tiger in the old days and it's like oh
back to health and Harmony and I say
what about today's world today's world
is 24 7 run from the tiger and this is
not biologically sustainable because uh
the chemistry of protection
contrasts with the chemistry of growth
in our mind we start to realize that
we're concerned we're afraid we don't
have enough I'm not safe I'm not secure
and I say oh these thoughts I was
talking about the thoughts in your mind
go in and control your biology your
genetics your physiology and your health
and I go yes this is really true I say
well how can I tell you what your
thoughts are in a sense that can I read
your thoughts and I say yes you know I
could put wires on your head and it's
called Electro and the graph and I could
read your brain activity and I go oh
great I can see this brain activity
I want to tell you something that's
profoundly important
we were programmed to believe that our
thoughts are contained in our head that
if I have a thought it's just for me not
for anybody else it's inside and it's
working through me
and now I want to tell you about a new
technology it's not
electroencephalograph it's called
magnetoencephalograph I say what's
unique about that I say read your brain
I say yeah but so does EEG I say yeah
but EEG put the wires on the head and
you get the electrical activity
conducted through the skin from the
brain and that's what I'm reading and I
said what's different about Meg
the probe is out here
and I said what does that mean
your thoughts are not contained in your
head your thoughts are broadcast to the
field just like a radio broadcast I said
well what if I as an individual have a
thought that says let's have peace in
the world
and I broadcast out there in the street
and I say let's have peace and I look
around it's like where's the piece I
don't see the piece and here's what the
relevance is
each of us is broadcasting
if you get enough people
to have the same thought
that broadcast is Amplified each of us
has a small power
but if you put a thousand people the
same thought ten thousand a hundred
thousand people with the same thought
you are broadcasting a most powerful
thought not just in your body but out in
the field I say your Energy's in the
field the thought is in the field and
you go well what does that mean and then
I'll give you this most wonderful quote
I used it the other day in a lecture
from Albert Einstein
and the quote is so important here's the
quote
the field so a definite definition the
field is the invisible energy right now
you're in a field there's cell phone
broadcast television television radio
broadcast all kinds of information
coming across but guess what each one of
you is a broadcast in that field the
quote the field
is the sole governing agency of the
particle
particle is the material Realm
so what was Einstein saying it's the
energy in the field that shapes the
physical experience of our lives and if
enough of us collectively have an energy
that's coherent and strong and we
broadcast the belief we change the world
I just want you to recognize as much as
I wanted peace in the world if not
enough people are out there saying let's
have peace in the world there is no
peace
if I want to say let's have a war how
can you have a war you have to have
enough people convinced that the war is
going to benefit them so that their
broadcasts say yes let's have a war
because I and my colleagues we're all
going to have a better result from that
and the reality is this
the only things that change on this
planet collectively are when we
collectively share thoughts
and yoga when you're in your postures
when you're in your process your mind is
sharing a thought not just in your head
but all around you so the whole idea
about this is we have to recognize we
are collectively creating reality with
our thoughts
and if we want to change reality it can
change instantly
the moment we become coherent the moment
we collectively are on the same platform
of thinking you get enough people to say
peace there will be peace instantly in
this world
but we've been programmed by other
people to give them the power to tell us
what we need
and as side Vegeta has been telling us
so importantly what we need is not what
they tell us what we need is what we
know
and I really hope that you understand
this because when you have your thoughts
recognized it's not contained in your
head your thoughts out in the field and
that thought the field is the sole
governing agency of matter
and therefore what this world is looking
for at this moment is an evolution
it's not an evolution of our biology our
biology has already evolved
it's an evolution of our consciousness
when we collectively as a population say
enough is enough it will end Jesus told
his followers all the Miracles that I
can do you can do them but even better
than I can and you don't believe it and
that was the whole damn thing in a
nutshell if you don't believe it you
can't do it and I said well where's
Believe come from mind I say and then
what have you been programmed you can't
do and I said then you'll never be able
to do it
and this is the problem and and so we
talked about way number one you want to
change it hypnosis because that's the
original way things went in in the first
place and you're you know you that what
you said was true the evenings just say
I feel amazing I feel amazing to repeat
that the mind will will all of a sudden
change how you feel that's that's how it
doesn't Okay so I say number one
self-hypnosis number two after age seven
you still learn how to do new things
that become habits like you didn't learn
how to drive a car until until later
than seven but once you know how to
drive a car remember the first day you
got in it was like oh my God looking out
the windows checking the mirror watching
the gauges keeping your feet on the
pedals just correctly you know looking
paying all these attentions like and I
say today you've been driving for a
while you don't even think about that
you get in the car you put the key in
and now what are you thinking about well
what am I going to do when I get to the
store you're not even thinking about
driving why it's a habit okay I say well
how did you get that habit because
you're older than seven how'd you get it
I said
repetition that's what makes a habit
practice you want to play an instrument
I'll hand you an instrument yeah you
didn't have any practice then you're not
going to be able to play it and I say oh
practice what is that repetition
that's the second way a subconscious
learns repeating something over and over
and over again because that's called
habituation making a habit and I love at
the new age today thing is fake it till
you make it I go what the hell is that I
say you're not happy yeah most of us
have trouble being happy and I say but
what if every day all day long and you
can remember you say I am happy in spite
of the fact of what the hell is going on
you just say I am happy I am happy I am
happy I go why what's going on I say
repetition and it'll be a point where
you'll repeat it to the degree that the
subconscious which learns by repetition
will put in I am happy I said then
what's the consequence they said what's
the function of the Mind take that
program and manifest it now that it's in
there I am happy I wake up one morning
guess what I don't have to say I'm happy
it's automatic I'm already happy all day
long life my program said that 95 is
coming from that habituation
you know repetition of the exact thing
you want not Future Vision as if you
have it now we'll put it in a program so
that's first seven years hypnosis after
seven years uh repetition habituation is
how you change it uh a sticky note
people put that stuff on a mirror or
someplace and they go oh yeah those
thinking out and I go that is not
repetition that's a suggestion a
repetition is a practice you have to
repeat things that's you practice an
instrument you practice driving a car
you practice doing these things and then
it became real okay so the first two
things are uh hypnosis second thing is
repetition and thirdly the most you know
is called Energy psychology and I go
what's energy psychology it's called
super learning you know so what the hell
is super learning I go maybe you've seen
somebody read a book by picking up a
book and just moving their finger down
the page just like that just as fast as
that
and guess what the subconscious mind the
super computer that it is has read every
word just by moving your finger down
around is read every word on that page
and a person using this super learning
technique and going to a bookstore open
up a book and five minutes later by
thumbing through each page Turn the Page
Turn the Page Turn the Page they can
read a whole book in five minutes that's
super learning I say if you can engage
that function
you can also use super learning to
create new programs not in days or weeks
but you can create a new program in
minutes it's like I go absolutely and
it's so important why because uh there's
an old phrase that's really critical
it's called necessity is the mother of
invention and I say what's happening
we're facing a mass extinction due to
human behavior that is compromising the
Web of Life humans are creating this
through our Behavior or culture I say
you want to survive this episode this
whole you know Extinction event well
then you have to create something
different you have to change Behavior
the thinking is not that much in our
control the brain is operating as I said
95 from the subconscious
but how did you actually then get
results in a relatively short space of
time well the first thing how does the
subconscious learn that's a very
critical thing uh the conscious mind can
learn from reading a book so you the
subconscious can mine can read a
self-help book and you go wow that
sounds really great and then you find
you read the book but your life is still
the same and it turns out why and the
answer is because the subconscious mind
is more of a habit mind things that you
repeat over and over again so the
reality is if you can stay conscious
be present and when those negative
thoughts come in our head and
psychologists tell us 70 of the time the
thoughts that are going through our head
are negative and redundant so the same
negative thoughts are going through if
you could stop those thoughts if you
could hear them as they come through
like oh that's not going to work oh this
will never happen those kind of thoughts
if you can hear them and stop them
consciously say no uh change the belief
right there just give the more positive
thing as you repeat this more frequently
and you keep repeating it the
subconscious mind begins to learn so as
a habit if you stay conscious and you
have to work at it and here's why people
say well how come only five percent from
conscious mind 95 from subconscious
because a conscious mind can think into
the future and think into the past and
solve problems then think about it
yourself most of the time you're
thinking about something well if you're
thinking you're using the conscious mind
well if you're using a conscious mind
for thinking then who's running the show
and the answer is when you're not paying
attention and you're thinking about what
I'm going to do tomorrow your
subconscious is running I mean I was a
scientist and as a scientist we don't
bring spirituality and mind into the
story it's all genes and cells and
molecules and all that and my research
uh on on stem cells uh revealed that
while I was teaching in medical school
that genes control life my research
revealed that it was the environment in
which the cells lived that control the
cells it was outside information coming
into the cells and I remember how
specifically in a moment of time that I
was working on trying to understand the
mechanics from a molecular point of view
how does an environmental signal control
biology and I was working not on the
genes I was working on the skin of the
cell the membrane and it was it was so
profound it's hard for me to even
describe it I'm working on the
understanding how does information from
the environment control biology and I
had looked at the membrane for years and
I wrote a new definition of the
mechanism of the membrane
and I wrote this definition and this is
in 1985. it was about 2 A.M and I wrote
down the membrane is a liquid Crystal
semiconductor with Gates and channels
when I wrote that down there was a pause
and I said I I just I read something
exactly like that and right next to my
first computer Macintosh was a book from
a simple book of understanding your
microprocessor and I opened it up and I
said somewhere and I open it right in
the introduction it said a chip
is a crystal semiconductor with Gates
and channels
and I thought oh what a coincidence they
have the same definition
and then in a couple of seconds I
started to say wait a minute one for one
the parts are exactly the same I said oh
oh my God the membrane is a computer
chip
and on the surface of the cellar like
Keys like on a typewriter and and I
started to realize oh my goodness the
environment is typing on the surface of
the cell information that went into the
cell and control the genetics and the
behavior and it was like oh oh this is
real exciting and I'm typing on my own
computer typing this information in and
then I realized I am outside of the
computer typing on the keyboard and the
information is coming up on the computer
then I said oh my God
this keyboard on the surface of your
cells has a number of keys that
represent a PIN number a personal
identification number and no two of you
have the same keys on that each of us
have a different pin number to get into
our own cells it's our personal identity
and these are the keys and I realized oh
my god well we've been focusing on these
what are called receptors as the source
of identity I realized no it's what's
activating what's typing is the identity
and then it hit me and said oh my God my
identity is not in the cell my identity
is a signal coming from the environment
typing on the keyboard and then I said
oh and the first thing that hit me was
I can't die I'm not even in here
and that instant of fear which all of us
have in our deepest bottom belief system
is a fear of mortality
and when that moment of like I can't die
not as a devotional belief it had
nothing to do with that it was just a
mechanism I said oh my God I can't die
I tell you the same thing happened with
Savages me
tears started rolling down my face and
this Joy was an ache in my heart that
I've never experienced before I spent 40
years in my head that's how I became an
academic Mission and a research
scientist and when this moment hit it
was my heart that blew open I refer to
it as a heart orgasm and
and that was the first time I
experienced my heart as a as an
essential part of my own conscious
existence and what happened was
I was overwhelmed first with the fact
that I was not spiritual at 1 59 a.m and
at 2 A.M I was 100 spiritual we have a
very close friend you know your friend's
behavior and you happen to know your
friend's parent and at some point you
see that your friend shares the same
behavior as their parent so you you know
you casually volunteer you go you know
Bill you're just like your dad and
that's when you have to back away from
bill because Bill's the first guy that
says how could you compare me to my dad
and everyone laughs because they're
familiar but I say no there's two very
profound points from that one story and
profound Point number one everybody else
can see that bill behaves like his dad
he got his programming from his dad it's
only Bill who doesn't see it and
profound Point number two we're all bill
because all of us got programming and
all of us operate with these programs
and we don't even see we're doing that
we even when told we're doing it will
deny that we do these behaviors because
we don't even see what we're doing
that's why it's called subconscious
below conscious when I first started
talking about it it was from an academic
conscious point of view this is what I
learned but my subconscious programs
were still exactly the same so well I
had this wonderful knowledge my life
still wasn't anything I wanted to to
brag about it because it wasn't and and
as you know that old gamer who would you
like to be and I could think of anybody
I'd rather be than me And yet when I
started to apply the new science and
rewrite the subconscious so it supported
me rather than the programs of
limitation or disempowerment that we get
from our parents and our community as
children which almost all of us get when
I put in the new programs all of a
sudden I started to find my goodness my
life completely turned around uh all
wonderful things started happening in my
life I was healthier I haven't been to a
doctor in 20 years I I don't need that I
don't take any of their drugs why
because most of the illness is just from
the stress of not living in Harmony and
when you learn to to get rid of the
limiting programs that we got as
children and put in programs that
support you guess what then all of a
sudden the place turns into heaven uh
and it's interesting to people I tell
people will you create your own life and
then they look around and go I don't
want responsibility for this but I say
well you didn't know you were creating
with these unconscious beliefs and and
yet then I tell people especially people
that have fallen in love and people have
fallen head over heels in love I said go
back to that time when you first fell in
love let me ask you a question were you
healthy and oh yeah I was I was healthy
as anything I said you have energy I
said oh I had so much energy made love
for days in a row without even eating
and I go yeah and I go uh and how was
life for you it was so exciting I
couldn't wait for the next day so I said
in this little period that you you know
that I refer to as a honeymoon I say
wasn't life like heaven on Earth and
they go well yeah and I go you know that
was not an accident that was an actual
creation and you say but what was
different that made life uh uh so heaven
on Earth during love and the answer is
because you become very self-conscious
of yourself you don't rely on the habits
the day before you meet this person
you're going to go on a date I say
especially the women I say how long did
it take to get dressed and they say well
I was 15 minutes and I was out of the
house and then I say now tonight you're
going to go on a date with this person
who has just rocked your world and I
said how long does it take you to get
dressed it's like my God it may take an
hour or two and I said yesterday 15
minutes today an hour or two what's the
difference yesterday I got dressed by
habit because I get dressed every day
but tonight I am looking in the mirror
meaning I am self-conscious I am making
sure that I represent myself to be the
fully the best individual I can be and
when both parties are not relying on the
habit and both of them are saying I'm
creating the best I can be they're
living in the moment of them now they're
being very mindful they're being very
present and guess what
heaven on Earth is created the cells in
your body are covered up by the skin
disconnected from the environment but in
order to survive these cells have to
adjust their genetics and their behavior
to adapt and maintain their survival in
a changing environment so the question
is then how do the cells inside your
body actually know what's going on in
the real world because they're not
connected to it I go this is the role of
the nervous system the nervous system's
job is to read environmental signals and
then relay those signals into the cell
so as Illustrated right here we are
getting signals from two different
environments in our body signals from
within our body as well as signals from
without our body and the function of the
nervous system is to read both of these
environments the relevance is the
nervous system reads the information in
the environment and then translates it
into signals that are sent to the 50
trillion cells inside your body to alert
them to what is going on in that world
so in fact that is a true statement the
environment is controlling the behavior
of your cells but the Mind does an
interpretation of those signals based on
our life experiences now for a lot of
people this seems difficult but let's
put it in a different context because we
can talk about computers there's a very
interesting fact about our brain as a
computer because it has an autocorrect
mechanism built into the subconscious
meaning what well I could have my
conscious mind like typing on the
computer about what's going on in the
world
but if I type something that signal can
be translated and sent to the cells but
if I type something that the
subconscious has no recognition of it
will do like an autocorrect and change
what I wrote to fit something that it
thinks that I wrote as a subconscious so
I put in the love and subconscious
changes that to live that's a whole
different meaning at this point because
of misinterpretation so the point is
your wishes and desires of your
conscious mind are filtered by the
programs in your subconscious mind and
if you have a wish or desire that
doesn't conform to a program that
already exists then the subconscious
mind's job is to re-translate that into
something that makes sense for the
subconscious belief not for the
conscious so we may have wonderful
wishes and desires and if it doesn't
conform to the programs that we receive
the subconscious will change those into
something it understands to make sense
of what I just said consider using your
cell phone that you write something in
your cell phone such as let's put the
word epigenetics in the cell phone and I
go when I type epigenetics in the
database in the phone says I don't know
that word at all and then what does it
do it throws up different options that
could be closely related to epigenetics
and so the significance is if I put
something into my system that is not
supported by the the program
then the programming system will change
whatever I did to accommodate what it
believes is right now the issue about
this is well if I want to have
epigenetics in my phone then what I
really have to do is open up my
dictionary and add the word epigenetics
and now after that anytime I write
epigenetics the phone mechanism will
understand what I'm talking about well
going into the database and changing the
program is the function of what energy
psychology is all about it says if your
behavior is not conforming to your
wishes and desires then it will be
necessary to go into your program and
install new behaviors that you want to
manifest so now the brain will have a
reflection or resource of what you're
talking about so I really want to
emphasize the nature of biology of
belief is different than the fact that
just environment controls your genes and
I'll give you a very simple example of
what I mean by that but the fact that I
can have two people and the Very exact
same environment but each of these
individuals has a totally different
reaction to the environment so if it was
just environment that controlled your
genes and your behavior then both
individuals should have exact same
behavior but the reality is no the two
people have different responses to the
environment I go why same environment
but their minds have different
interpretations and it's the
interpretation of the mind about that
environment that is sent to the cells so
the important part is this yes
environment controls epigenetics
there's an external environment
but an internal environment
Annette recognizing humans the internal
environment is not a direct readout from
the external world it's an
interpretation of that external world
and that's why each of us has a
different response to the world in which
we live and that is why the biology of
belief is an extension of the foundation
that environment controls epigenetics
you want to change the world we don't
have to physically go out and physically
change the world first first we have to
change our belief about the world our
belief of who we are in the world we're
not victims but we've been programmed to
believe we're frail vulnerable that
we're victims of the world in fact is no
we are the most powerful beings and
entities on this planet we want to get
out of the box think out of the box and
that will change all of it as you
understand the terms quantum physics and
quantum mechanics or Newtonian physics
or Newtonian mechanics what you see is
that physics and mechanics are synonyms
so physics really means the mechanisms
by which the universe operates and the
new physics quantum physics was
something that I really wasn't into nor
were any of my colleagues in the medical
school we were all trained in Newtonian
physics and the difference between the
two is very profound Newtonian physics
says the world that we live in the
universe we live in is a machine made
out of mechanical Parts if you want to
understand how it works take it apart
study the pieces change the pieces
change the operation That's the basis of
medicine we look at a human body it's a
machine made out of physical parts when
it's not working right change the parts
by buying chemicals and drugs and that's
the way that conventional medicine
operates when I started to read the
quantum physics I realized oh my
goodness the the whole foundation of the
universe is not based on a mechanical
physical Universe it's based on the
invisible energy called the field so
let's say if I hold a magnet right here
in front of you and you can see the
magnet but what you can see is the
invisible magnetic field and so what it
says is well we are physical things in
our world like physical bodies we're
immersed in fields electro magnetic
fields magnetic fields itself all kinds
of fields like telephone cell phone
Fields television Fields radio Fields
whole ranges
what is the difference between the
Newtonian physics and the quantum
physics is this Newtonian physics focus
on the particles quantum physics says
you want to understand why the particles
take this shape then you have to
understand the field it's the field that
controls biology it's the invisible
forces there's a great quote by Albert
Einstein and it's simple it goes the
field is the soul governing agency of
the particle
in other words in the world of invisible
things fields and particles matter
it's the field that gives shape to the
matter and this is the basis of quantum
physics this becomes relevant it says
okay here's the physical particles of my
body why are they in a healthy state or
why could they be in a sick State that's
the physical expression and the answer
is well to understand that don't look at
the body you have to understand the
invisible forces in the field
it's fun because if you think about it
when when of course when you were young
at some point you must have had like
iron filings and sprinkled it around a
magnet and all of a sudden you saw the
iron filings form that pattern of the
magnetic field
well quantum physics would look at this
pattern and try to explain how come all
the iron filings fell in this pattern
without recognizing that the field
exists in other words can you explain
why the iron filings have this shape if
you don't recognize a magnetic field the
answer is absolutely not what's the
nature of it the body and its cells are
like iron filings medicine is trying to
understand the nature of the body by
looking at the iron filings and quantum
physics says if you don't understand
that invisible field you can't ever
understand what's happening in the body
what you we would see from a new
understanding of evolution which is a
great extension beyond the darwinian
belief belief which is quite limiting
okay and quite Troublesome in fact uh
because just think about what the
principle darwinian belief is that
evolution is based on a struggle for
survival with a competition for Fitness
so that says oh my God then our world is
we're all out there and a dog eat dog
Rat Race trying to survive because if
you stop running the person behind you
is going to run over you so if that's
your way of live than every day by
definition you are living in a stress
hormone body because of all the fears
that we that we have and yet Evolution
says no evolution is based on community
and cooperation a body has 50 trillion
citizens they live in harmony with each
other and it turns out that every human
being we're beginning to find out is
like a cell in a larger Community called
Humanity so in biological terms the
organism that's evolving on the planet
is not the human being we already did
that the organism that's evolving is the
super organism called human civilization
and right now humans are fighting each
other and killing each other and if I
say well what would that look like
inside the body if the cells fight each
other and kill each other and I say oh
well that's called autoimmune disease
self-destruction and and autoimmune
disease can kill you from the inside and
that's on the increase isn't it oh
absolutely because because our
biological lives are compliments to the
environment The more stress and more
violence on the outside the more that's
taken inside in biology and converted to
uh disruption and disharmony of your own
cellular internal Community if you can
create a honeymoon for yourself while
you're in love and everyone started to
create a honeymoon for themselves then
all of a sudden the concept of war and
violence would disappear because if
everybody's in love and everybody's in
Harmony and everybody's so excited by
being here then the competition and
violence that we live by because of
today's beliefs would disappear because
we've been so programmed to devalue
ourselves and deep you know disempower
ourselves that we look at ourselves as
victims and frail uh biological entities
you know ripe for bacteria to eat us up
and all these other things it's like
this is totally untrue so the issue is
we have to start from that belief and
change these beliefs of who we are we
are profoundly powerful people look you
can walk across cross hot coals you know
a woman can lift a car off of an infant
without thinking about it
down south the Baptist fundamentalists
of the Pentecostal Faye worked
themselves up in a Jesus State and drink
strict nine and toxic doses to
demonstrate that God protects them
they're not harmed by the strychnine I
mean you can walk across fire you can
drink poison you can lift thousands of
pounds where's the frail image come from
and that's a belief but the problem is
if you believe you are frail if you
believe you are susceptible if you
believe you have a terminal illness they
manifest because that's called the
nocebo effect you as an identity are in
your conscious mind you actually are in
there that's where your personal
identity is
and we have a tendency to say if I talk
to myself I'm going to give myself a
good talking to and I'm going to change
that subconscious I say to myself Bruce
don't do that again do this don't do
that again and and then I say it's very
frustrating why you can talk until
you're blue in the face
and nothing will change I say why and
the answer is and this is the most
important part
there is nobody in the subconscious
there's nothing there it's a machine
it's a record playback device so you can
talk to the machine as much as you want
if you don't know how to push the record
button nothing's going to happen so that
I say how do you change the program I
say how did you get the program the
first seven years your brain was in
Theta hypnosis
so I say you want to change a program
every night when you go to bed just as
your mind disconnects just as you fall
into sleep your brain is now operating
in Theta so if you put earphones on your
head
and you play a tape a program a CD of
what you want
as your your conscious mind disconnected
your subconscious is downloading so you
just play that tape as you go to bed and
after a number of playings your
subconscious will learn the new program
without even your conscience being
involved that's number one after age
seven how do we put a program in
repetition how did you do anything you
repeated it over and over again how long
did it take you to learn the alphabet
how many times did you have to go from A
to Z before you could remember the whole
alphabet when you drove a car you didn't
know how to drive a car until you did
what you practiced you repeated so if
you want to change a program you put
into your mind a repetition and it's not
it recognize this what you want to
change doesn't exist so when you put in
the new program it'll sound strange so
let's say you are sick you have a
disease and I say what program do I want
I am healthy
I go it doesn't sound right I know I'm
sick I say I don't care there's a saying
in English fake it until you make it
what that means is if you want to be
happy just keep in your mind I am happy
I smile even if you have to force a
smile I am happy I'm smiling I say
repeat this and repeat this and guess
what after a short time it becomes a
habit
and when you're in that habit you don't
even have to think I am happy the new
habit will keep you happy all the time
because that's the new program well I
probably don't have to tell you this if
you've been watching TV reading the
newspaper going online or even looking
out your window the world is in a state
of upheaval crises are all over the
planet crises based on economics
politics religion race are upsetting the
nature of civilization as we have known
it well this is not an accident actually
this is right on time on time yes we're
facing an evolutionary upheaval the
significance is profound science has
recognized that human behavior is
precipitating the sixth mass extinction
of Life on this planet five times in the
history of this planet life was thriving
in some event wiped out from 70 to 95
percent of all life the last time this
happened 66 million years ago a comet
hit the planet upended the Eco ecosystem
and the dinosaurs disappeared forever
well guess what we are now in the sixth
mass extinction human behavior is
causing this the way out is to change
Behavior but to understand that we need
to understand that you are not a victim
not a victim of your dreams not a victim
of the world as quantum physics
emphasizes Consciousness is creating our
life experiences when I show up on
September 27th in Copenhagen on Friday
night I'm going to provide a
presentation to inform you of why this
upheaval is occurring the future of our
Evolution and more importantly how
powerful you are in creating the
character of the life you want as
quantum physics the most valid science
on this planet acknowledges
Consciousness is creating our life
experiences well my presentation will go
deep into the nature of Consciousness
and how our mind controls our genes
controls the behavior that we have and
the life that we express and when you
unders stand that you've been programmed
and it's time for us to get out of this
program to recognize how truly powerful
you are this is the opportunity to take
charge of your life and so what we need
to understand is this a you are not a
victim of your heredity because
epigenetics the new science reveals that
you are controlling your genetic and
behavioral activity and more so
we want to understand a very important
fact there's more to us in this physical
body that there's a field of energy with
our identity which is also recognized as
a spirit and if you recognize how
powerful you really are and that you are
more than this physical body you will
have the opportunity to take charge of
your life and create the wishes and
desires and aspirations that you seek so
someone's not feeling well they've got
I don't know they've got the flu or
they've got someone with their stomach
or something what should they
practically do they should presumably go
to the doctor and get a diagnosis would
you go along with that I'm just I'm just
trying to see where this goes in
day-to-day life well I wouldn't say
don't go to a doctor but I say before
you go to a doctor just look around and
think about this what's going on in your
life where are the stresses coming from
because it's almost uh you're a
physiological expression is a compliment
to your life experiences those people
that are happy or healthy as I said when
you're in the honeymoon you didn't get
sick in the honeymoon that's when you're
absolutely healthy but when you got
caught back up into real life that's
when illnesses start to occur so we
always look at oh I must be sick there
must be something wrong with my biology
when it turns out it didn't begin with
your biology only about two percent of
illness is actually connected to
genetics let's say 98 of illness is not
just genetics it's environment so when a
person says I have the breast cancer
Gene and people think oh I'm going to
get breast cancer and I said well wait
wait 50 of women that have the breast
cancer Gene get cancer
what about the 50 that have the Gene and
didn't get the cancer and we never study
that side we only study the side they
got the cancer and you find out well
what is it that the 50
do that don't have the cancer yet have
the gene what's different the answer is
their lifestyle is different their
stresses their fears their concerns are
are not the same as the one that get the
illness the genes are like give you a
propensity to get a disease but that
propensity is based on how you perceive
life
uh and it's interesting uh studies show
that when children get adopted into a
cancer family the adopted child will get
the cancer with the same percentage of
probability as any of the natural
sibling and you say yeah but the the
child came from totally different
genetic stock and the point is yes it
wasn't the genes that promoted the
cancer it was the lifestyle that
promoted the cancer especially the
lifestyle of stress and then you say
well if stress is causing livestock I
look around at the world I go my God no
wonder everybody's sick every day is
filled with more stress than the day
before and if you buy into the stress
you take that disharmonious vibration
essentially bring it in your life and
you end up with disharmony inside your
body your life is a reflection of what
you see they did a recent study where
they looked at some genes controlling
inflammation
and then they had they read the genes of
these people
and then the people went to eight hours
of meditation and at the end of eight
hours the genetic activity was
completely changed in other words you
can change the genes in just eight hours
of a meditation and that means how
powerful your thought is in controlling
your biology I don't want to say don't
go to the doctor so I'll go back just 20
years ago the last time I went to a
doctor okay I went to a doctor because I
had pneumonia and I said to myself well
you know I can see why at that moment in
my life there was so much stress going
on in my life that I could see I was I
had opened my system up to that but then
I also realized okay well I can you know
handle this with my Consciousness but
then I realized the bacteria were
doubling and they're growing faster than
I can handle my Consciousness so I said
okay Now's the Time for some penicillin
but the concept of it was I don't rely
on the penicillin and and all I had to
say was look I get back on my feet and I
go it was my responsibility and if I
don't get into that same stressful
situation again then I won't have to go
through this again and it's been 20
years so it's intelligent learning yes
don't don't discard the element of
medicine until your Consciousness gets
high and the fact is when people have
lower consciousness
because they're not strong enough in
their Consciousness to really manifest
everything they want they really need to
take care of themselves more eat better
better nutrition do more exercises do
these things to add to your health but
the surprising thing is if you get more
and more and more conscious there's a
point where you get so conscious then
you become like uh the the person we
refer to as Jesus who does all these
Miracles and well and what did what what
did Jesus say about the Miracles he said
you could do these better than I could
do them but you don't believe and that
is the absolute truth because when you
fully have control of your consciousness
with that belief you do create the
Miracles the Miracles of spontaneous
remission for example a person
terminally ill who all of a sudden says
I'm not buying this I'm going to change
my vision of life and the moment they
change their perception they have What's
called the spontaneous remission again
that would be called a miracle but what
was it taking full control of
Consciousness and manifesting a life of
being fully conscious and present and
and seeing what brings Harmony into your
life and avoiding or eliminating as best
you can any of the disharmony that
exists on the outside because disharmony
will make disharmony inside this is the
truth
but if you really understand this truth
you have to change the way you're living
because you're living by some
materialistic darwinian Newtonian give
me more matter I'll be happier and it's
like there's nothing to do with that at
all
because happiness is is not an object
and so what's a revolution well we've
been programmed on materialism it could
be more matter
and it's like no because what do you get
I love it because we just like a
training session and there was this
professional wrestling
and his
Persona in the ring is like a bad guy
so he has to dress up and you know do
the acting and the wrestling
and everybody would boo-boo him that was
his job to be booed you know and he came
to say okay because he was really
depressed by it why because his job is
to be hated by people it's like well
that's not a great job but uh so we said
well what are you looking for he said
well
if I could um maybe be an announcer
for this uh you know I could be an
announcer and then they said okay and
you get to be an announcer and what is
that what's that good for well if I get
to be announcer then maybe a network
will pick me up and then I could be a
sportscaster
oh yeah and then one he said well then
I'll have some more money
and then what so then buy more things
that was it then I could buy some more
whatever he said and then and finally
you know because we kept pushing to the
last one it was like and and what do you
get from getting this and finally after
a litany
I'll be happy happiness I'll be happy so
uh River Rob and I looked at him and Rob
says well you could be happy from day
one you didn't need to do any of this
stuff to be happy because even if he
actually did do all of those yes even if
you simply could say well that was a
circuitous route but at the end it did
bring happiness that would be different
but we know you go through this whole
circuitous route and don't pick it up
and you're still not happy no that's
what the rich people are they got all
this money but they're not happy and
it's like yeah well you could buy
anything you want it's like yeah but at
some point buying is not happy it was I
was happy to have it I said well happy
yeah it didn't have to be it happy could
be happy and uh but people have been
programmed
yes to conform to a machine
that requires some a to work and B
consumed work and consume work and
consume and that will make this machine
work like this I'm mad as heck but I
will take it anymore
[Music]
how many people go through the process
find it doesn't work and then repeat the
process and doesn't work again it's like
oh oh yeah I've been married four times
somebody was saying it's like God they
repeated the same error already three
times with the ideas do you think by the
fourth time maybe you could learn that
whatever pattern you played three times
in a row will probably play itself again
until you change not your partner you
keep bringing in the same partner with
different colored hair and a different
name but you're still you brought that
person in and you play the same game
over again the question is can you learn
the answer is you can but do many people
learn the answer is no because they keep
thinking that it's just my fate you know
that's just the way life is the
subconscious Still Remains unconscious
that's the problem until you change the
subconscious program you it's the
subconscious is a habitual mind it's a
habit until you change the Habit you
will be replay the Habit that's why it's
called a habit so you keep replaying the
same program it's like yeah you keep you
know it's like the definition of
insanity is the idea of keep doing the
same thing and expect something
different to happen the fact is though
that's insane why you keep doing the
same thing you're going to get the same
thing
and if the Habit mind is giving us a
story then the answer says well how do I
change it answers change the
subconscious mind because that's where
the habits are that we got from other
people again this is most important the
fundamental habits in the subconscious
mind came from other people and that's
why they rarely match what you want in
your conscious mind which is you
and you create those programs and yet
the fundamental programs the
subconscious were downloaded during that
first six years of our development how
do you rewire your brain
well as we just said the first thing you
have to do is say what the heck are my
programs you don't have to fix a program
if it works the only one you want to fix
is the one that doesn't work so then you
say well what are the programs and I can
already tell you the things that don't
work in your life that you desire to
have in your life and you are creating
an effort and a struggle and a lot of
work to make it happen the reason why
it's not working is because somewhere in
the program it doesn't support that
conclusion so this program does not
allow you to have this so the thing is
well as long as I have this program I'm
never going to get this and even if I
get it it's going to disappear if I you
know as soon as I let go of the control
it's going to disappear because sabotage
away so the first thing is identify well
where are you having trouble
uh and I said whatever that destination
is that the thing you were looking for
whether it was a job Health relationship
whatever if that's where you're having a
trouble recognize this the program is
counter to that it does it's the
opposite the program is the opposite
that's why this can't stay here because
this is gonna 95 of the day create a
different program not the one you wanted
so I say so if I have a troubled
relationship then basically uh my
program for a relationship doesn't work
very well in my case that was true I uh
you know for 50 years I was operating
from the program of relationship that I
downloaded from my parents who had a
really sucky relationship it was so bad
and I was just manifesting it
unconsciously until I started a change
once I changed
now I have heaven on Earth we came here
to create
we came here to experience love we have
a sensory system if it's not love it
takes us away from our creation we came
here to have the joy of what heaven on
Earth and all of a sudden I say Earth is
heaven Earth is where you came to create
and then if you get misdirected in your
creation you can then create the world
that we have a world that doesn't look
that good to me you know uh and I guess
so why is this all relevant is because
we are truly powerful creators and we
have given up
the belief that we have any power at all
I'm afraid of this I'm afraid of that
and I'm going well there you go fear
means close down growth is open the
opposite growth is to be open and in
love fear is to close down and
protection we cannot survive by closing
down anything that closes down will buy
and so we have to it's the fear and then
I say so what about Bruce because you
might ask me that question
What stopped the fear in my life was I
owned my spirituality as a scientific
reality I didn't go through a devotional
phase not spiritual and then I had to
learn a lot of stuff and then I became
spiritual I was a biologist
and saw I am not in here I am a
broadcast and that moment of I cannot
die you cannot die you're not in there
but you have to not
you know like have a Devotion to
spirituality it's either you believe
spirituality you don't believe it and
for me it wasn't a devotion it was a
scientific mechanism
and the relevance was the moment I saw
that my life just like boom
what happened I said I lost fear
and if you're not in fear no one can
control you
because fear is what makes you give up
the power to someone else something you
look at in spontaneous Evolution too is
how science and spirituality are coming
together they used to be very separate
usually absolutely the the scientific
World which is very factual driven and
that's that and you couldn't change it
and spirituality was trying to open up
things but they really are meeting now
aren't they yeah it was interesting
because um the spiritual world of
religion was talking about the invisible
moving forces that shaped the physical
reality and we call them spirit and then
science uh only came into existence
because it made a detaunt with the
church in the very early days of science
it said look we won't tread on your
invisible spiritual domain we will just
study the physical world and when Newton
was able to predict the movements of the
planet by just looking at the physical
features then scientists got the ideas
well if you can understand how the
universe operates by just studying the
material where we don't need that
invisible stuff but in 1925 Newtonian
physics was incorporated subsumed by a
bigger physics called quantum physics
and quantum physics emphasizes the
universe is made out of energy it's not
made out of matter and then I say well
what does the quantum physicist call
this energy that the universe is made of
I say well they call it the field I said
what's the definition of the field I
love this invisible moving forces that
influence the physical world I go my
goodness that's the same definition as
spiritual it's used for spirit I go yes
quantum physics emphasizing the
invisible uh field as primary to the
physical world is essentially
reiterating the statement of the
spiritual people who talked about the
invisible forces shaping our physical
existence and so by definition
science the new science of quantum
physics is bringing us back into
alignment with a spiritual reality
hopefully uh the the dogmatic beliefs of
the church which had talked about these
wonderful terms but didn't allow us to
live there and science which is still
stuck in its material plane will both
divest themselves of their dogma and
allow us to come together and recognize
that we're all part of that invisible
field that that we don't even live in
our own bodies if you understand the
nature of how the cell works so we are
part of the field being downloaded into
our body that we're all by definition
the field or we're all spiritual same
definition and and if we recognize this
the unity of it and that you cannot be
taken out of the field and you cannot be
in a sense punished by the field you are
the field then maybe the beliefs those
very restrictive beliefs from both
science and from the dogmatic religion
will disappear but because the people
owning their own spirituality owning
their own responsibility and not saying
oh which spirits that did this or things
other factors that we are the creators
will generate a new world because what I
firmly believe is very simple go out and
talk to the average person anywhere in
the world and say if you could create a
world what would you like well I'd like
a world where there's peace and Harmony
and I like some food and a job and I go
isn't it amazing how everywhere you go
in the world virtually entire population
has the same belief I go then how come
we don't have an answer is because the
leadership isn't exercising that belief
so I trust the people
to take over the leadership of this
world and that the structure that is is
actually in a state of collapse when it
collapses this will be our opportunity
to evolve from the very destructive
darwinian perception of a world
into a more holistic holism that says
we're all part of the same system we're
all cells in the same body and when we
work together we will create Magic on
this earth like nothing has ever been
seen before so I'm very optimistic about
it because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome
if you want another amazing Bruce Lipton
clip check it out right there next to me
I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there